it's christmas which means i've got a
new doctor who t-shirt and
there's a new christmas special for me
to talk about
last christmas it's always interesting
to me to see how much the idea of
christmas itself actually gets
integrated into any given christmas
special and oddly
counter-intuitively almost the ones that
seem to integrate christmas
more directly into the story are the
ones i tend to like a lot more so
given the fact that we have nick frost
appearing as santa claus in this uh yeah
i like this pretty well it's actually a
really interesting contrast with this in
terms of
how just light by nature
santa claus himself as a character is
and his interactions with other
characters
but how dark and creepy and gets under
your skin
the entire rest of the episode is i
don't really want to get into plot too
much
even giving a synopsis beyond just dr
and santa claus team up
i feel like it's giving away too much of
this the the narrative is twisty and
turny enough that really sort of
figuring out as it goes along is part of
what makes it work and i i'm not going
to take that away from you not without
warning at any rate
this episode also has a really good
supporting cast for it
they're basically four other characters
which would normally consider
to be sort of the fodder characters in
your sort of victim pool like yeah they
may not make it all the way through this
and they're all good they're all solid
they're all well developed and
well-played
which is actually something we've gotten
a lot of in just series eight in general
the
the toss-off fodder characters have
actually been pretty good and pretty
interesting in
almost every episode and this one is not
an exception i think my favorite stuff
though is
banter between santa and the doctor the
the two just have just the nature of
their personality santa by his nature
warm and bubbly the doctor by his nature
cold and
cranky the two of them just bouncing off
each other it's
just so much fun nick frost was really a
sublime bit of casting because i mean in
reality he's
he would not usually be considered to
play standard because he's way too young
he they
had to you know gray up the beard on him
but he works really well and he's
warm and he's fun and he's energetic
he's got a couple of elves with him too
and they're good for a few laughs
but like i said the show just really
balances that
the fun and the scary very very well
and in a way that it could have very
easily felt schizophrenic but it just
as the episode builds it just all sort
of mashes together these two disparate
elements they just become closer and
closer intermingled and it
it just works i'm not in love with
everything though actually specifically
i got some issues with the ending and
i'm gonna do something i
rarely do generally if i talk spoilers i
do a completely separate video i don't
have the energy to do it on this i'm
gonna talk about it in this one so
if you have not seen that episode yet if
you haven't seen last christmas and you
want no spoilers
this is the point you need to get out of
here turn off this video
if you are still around i am about to
spoil
almost everything so last chance
still here all right here we go the
major thing
i have an issue with is the fact that
clara is not
gone i mean this is blatantly at the end
the dr ian claro will return
i don't want clara to return i've said
repeatedly in my reviews
across series eight even though she is
better now than she ever was before i'm
done with her i'm bored with clara i and
especially now
that danny pink is dead i really don't
see
anything that can be done to make her
work because a big part of what made her
work the series for me
was what was going on with danny pink
well he's now gone
so i don't see how they're gonna keep
her interesting at all even the little
bit that they managed to make her in
series eight
it actually irritates me even more
because she had two
completely legitimate workable i was
good with them
send-offs she had one at the end of
death in heaven
i would have been completely fine with
that being her last appearance it would
have been fine
and i would have been fine with this one
being her last appearance up
until the very very end because the
whole episode deals with
dreams within dreams yes it gets a bit
inceptiony it's it's basically inception
meets alien so there's all that stuff
but
where it should have ended there was one
wake up to many
when the doctor goes to get the crab off
of clara's face and find her
62 years later from the last time he saw
her and she's just
she's lived her life it was bittersweet
it was a little sad but it felt
right it felt fitting it should have
ended there but then he wakes up
one more time goes to her she's still
that young clara
that we've always known and he rescues
her and now they go off together and
we're going to get
a whole other series with clara and it's
actually even more irritating because
they give
danny pink a great last sort of
secondary send-off in this as well
which just sort of emphasizes how good
clara is with
him but he's dead i suppose i i will add
a slight ass for a song to this i
suppose it's possible they're going to
find some ridiculous way to bring him
back because they still haven't really
resolved the fact that we saw
what was very clearly their descendant
in listen and he's
in the future i don't know if that's
just going to get dropped and sort of
chalked up to the whole well the
timeline got changed i guess that guy
doesn't exist anymore or if they're
actually going to reconcile that which
would
potentially involve bringing danny back
somehow i god i really hope not though
up until that very end i i thought this
was a wonderful episode i thought it was
fun it was touching it was scary
it was twisty once you realized that we
were dealing with dreams
seeing where it was going was not
particularly difficult
you never really felt like you got the
rug pulled out from under you but it was
still all handled in a very clever
fashion it's just
that that last scene why so if you stuck
all the way through this i'm assuming
you saw the episode as well because i
just spoiled the heck out of it for you
so
what were your thoughts on last
christmas are you happy that clara's
sticking around are you annoyed that
she's sticking around
did you love the episode did you hate it
whatever you thought about it drop
something down with comments and let's
talk about it until next time this
council
is adjourned
you